vous m'entendez là
bonsoir Claude ça va très bien vous êtes
en bonne compagnie là Elodie Navarre
alors Claude à part le journal Le Monde
à part les émissions de Laurent Huquier
à part le théâtre vous êtes l'auteur de
nombreux livres dont le dernier publié
chez plomb s'appelle d'Ivoire ma minette
c'est moi
76 ans une vraie battante qui a vraiment
la pêche et puis qui discute avec ses
filles adoptives à ni tête et Carole
elle passe leur temps à se moquer d'elle
en fait mais elles peuvent pas se passer
de ses conseils
quand les jeunes femmes maintenant et
elles ont des problèmes grands mecs avec
leur carrière avec leur beaux enfants et
familles recomposer tout ça et moi je
suis terriblement donneuse de conseils
j'arrête pas de me mêler de leur vie tu
vois jusqu'au moment où à la fin du
livre ils vont me dire qu'elles en ont
un peu marre
vous êtes agacé donc par ce racisme
antivieu qui en ce moment
politiquement correcter ni les Noirs
il est femme ni les juif alors il reste
que les vieux moi il reste moins et je
me bats pour moi pour les vieux
livre sans sommeil
il y a des vieux handicapés des vieux
noirs
je me bats sur le fait qu'on se moque
d'eux parce qu'ils sont vieux tu vois
vous êtes la seule vedette seniors du
PAF Claude non oui au moins je suis la
mamie du PAF ça c'est tout ce qu'on peut
dire c'est ça qui m'a donné l'écrire ce
livre vous dites plus je vieillis plus
j'en profite quand même oui maintenant
je m'en fous je dis ce que je pense
aussi il y a une menace
j'en ai pris la DH
ça réveille la libido et ça ne marche je
t'assure une catastrophe
alors tu pourras les vieilles dames de
70 ans et plus dont on réveille la
libido c'est très frustrant la plupart
non plus de partenaires
et des potes à moi
maison un grand frigo
c'est très vrai un petit jeune de 17 ans
Claude ça vous plairait pas un petit
jeune de 17 ans tu vois je trouve ça
obscène
sérieusement c'est pour pas tromper
Jean-François Revel ou c'est parce que
vous n'avez pas envie
je dépassé ce stade voilà encore une
liberté tu t'en fous d'avoir un mec tu
sais quand on a fait beaucoup l'amour il
y a un moment on commence à avoir
ras-le-bol ah bon mais oui on se lasse
j'ai beaucoup fait l'amour dans votre
vie beaucoup j'adorais ça
[Applaudissements]
moi je comprends vous prenez un peu de
dhe ça va réveiller votre libido et les
copains de Stomy bugs
avec 5 mecs
il faut montrer tes bras plisser tes
vieilles cuisses tes fesses qui tombent
un peu on prend l'argent et on s'en va
alors parler aussi dans votre livre de
la virginité vous dites jeune fille je
préservais jalousement ma virginité pour
être sûr de dégoter un beau parti
c'était mon petit capital
complet
évidemment on n'allait pas le galvauder
comme ça tu sais la remarque la plus
extraordinaire que j'ai entendue c'est
quelqu'un qui disait
c'est absurde pendant une fille qui
n'est pas vierge tu vas pas acheter un
paquet de cigarettes ouvert voilà
60 ans
c'est important aujourd'hui cette mine
et
virginités mais des religions mais là où
c'est dangereux c'est comme quand une
femme a connu qu'un seul homme dans sa
vie
après plus tard il y a des fantasmes qui
viennent
la sexualité des filles se développe
beaucoup plus tard que celle des garçons
un ado ou un garçon de 16-18 ans il est
conduit par son sexe il pense qu'à une
seule chose baiser baiser une fille pas
du tout elle si elle veut être aimée
voilà alors quand elles se font des
pucer trop tôt elles sont pas heureuses
pour autant vous êtes d'accord avec ça
mauvaise donc je
ben Claude aussi a une expérience assez
mauvaise la première fois à l'âge de 12
ans j'étais à moitié violée par un ami
de votre père
ce sont des enfants comme moi un peu qui
me plaît et alors ton père ou ton ami
Ton père il te caresse tu vois il
prolonge les caresses qu'on te fait à 6
mois deux ans trois ans et tu prolonges
et moi ça me faisait plutôt plaisir ça
me flattait plutôt et donc il est arrivé
à ça très naturellement
pour que je pense à hurler que je me
suis
c'était un malade donc quand j'ai
rencontré ce premier mari américain oui
ben oui voilà il a mis 6 mois à me
dépuceler chaque fois qu'il s'approchait
de l'endroit stratégique je disais
attention tu es malade tu es malade va
pas là le bout de 6 mois ça a été ouais
parce qu'on s'est formidablement disputé
et rien de plus affreux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elles font ce que je trouvais qu'il
fallait faire j'ai toujours fait
d'ailleurs et alors mec les trompes elle
lui rendent la monnaie de sa pièce au
sous près c'est pas de se mettre en
déshabiller de faire la danse du ventre
ça ne sert à rien
alors tout ça c'est c'est des souvenirs
que vous avez que vous écrivez peut-être
qu'un jour quand vous serez dans votre
maison de retraite Claude vous y
penserait
une interview maison de retraite
les vieux nos rêves plus
vous m'entendez là
vous voulez boire quelque chose oui une
verveine une camomille du champagne du
champagne la tension ça va la tension ah
oui bien sûr ça va bien oui
le boulot d'une jeune qui en plus votre
trade d'ailleurs
tu me fais quoi de savoir que plus
personne n'aura de n'aura de retraite
après vous moi j'y crois pas je crois
que tout le monde aura la retraite tu
vas voir les manifestations la semaine
prochaine on est obligé de verser des
retraites
ça me fait très plaisir
ça vous manque la chance de chansons que
j'ai jamais vu la chanson chanson
il se passe quoi en ce moment d'un amour
gloire et beauté
que c'est une de City ça c'est
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu